major news in the last six to ten hours
joe biden has agreed to meet with
russian president vladimir putin in
principle if putin has not invaded
ukraine at the time that the meeting or
summit would take place and this is
interesting because to some degree you
could say well russia has kind of
already invaded ukraine
and that has different meanings
depending on what you're referring to
whether it's crimea or whether it's
these uh
individual explosions that are being
misattributed okay we we can define that
a few different ways but the point is
if putin does not invade ukraine
however it is that we are defining that
uh joe biden has agreed in principle to
meet with with vladimir putin now joe
biden is kind of mediocre in many areas
in this particular area he's
particularly well suited and in fact if
you said
in what scenario should we be the most
happy that it's joe biden and not donald
trump
it's exactly the situation saying an
american president has an opportunity to
stop a global calamity that will wreak
absolute havoc on our economy and on
people around the world
that this is the scenario this is the
scenario let's see what happens and
although on the one hand biden agrees in
principle to meet with putin
and there have been reports that such a
summit
is going forward
uh the kremlin denies that there are any
concrete plans for a putin biden summit
at this time and so we are going to have
to wait and see what happens there
russian president putin's spokesman said
just hours ago there were no plans yet
for a new summit with joe biden
contradicting claims from the white
house which said the leaders agreed in
principle so that's why the headline on
cnbc is biden agrees
but so far
kremlin denies and this is going to be a
this is a i would argue this is a bigger
geopolitical test and calamity
really than anything that happened under
trump i mean trump will say well no i
went and met with kim jong-un
and then i got him to make these
promises but you know these are the same
promises that north korean leaders have
made to american presidents for a long
time and
trump was just so naive in that and i i
think that this is uh this is far far
more than that and you know at the end
of the day just look at the markets
right the markets will tell you what is
the bigger calamity and the markets were
quite calm when the entire north korea
thing was happening the markets are
erratic right now uh know that if biden
meets with putin and putin ends up not
invading and there's no war the
anti-biden are gonna people are gonna
spin this really really hard you know
they're already calling him a warmonger
now even though biden has already ruled
out that the us would send troops
multiple times but it doesn't matter
and if war is averted here and joe biden
is involved the anti-biden people on the
left and right will say putin was never
going to invade anyway you know those
190 000 troops on three sides of ukraine
they were there on vacation or whatever
biden was just hyping it that's one
thing that they will claim there was
never any risk of invasion anyway uh
they will say you know joe biden is
against our troops because he kept them
from having something to do i mean it
just you know like absurd on its face
they'll say it was really trump's
friendship with putin before biden that
prevented the war
they'll say oh well putin clearly made
some demand of biden and biden accepted
it because biden is so weak
or maybe they'll say rudy called putin
secretly
maybe hunter biden's laptop will be
thrown in there or hillary in some way
they'll claim it was the canadian
truckers who convinced putin to back off
or whatever anyway the point is
they will spin this no matter what
happens against joe biden so let's try
to follow the fact of what's happening
right now we have
a very very uh
sensitive intense situation there
my hope is
there is no war
and let's see if joe biden can help
prevent that
it's not it's not the us's
responsibility to prevent it
but
if joe biden is able to actually get
something done
uh i am all for it and i'm glad that
it's not trump that's being put in that
position
let me know your thoughts
let me know what you expect and i mean
you know things are moving so quickly
that by the time this clip publishes
russia may have already been invaded may
have already invaded ukraine um let me
know find me on twitter at dpakman we'll
be right back
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping